when the air raid sirens sound in the
city of marhanets warning of an incoming
Russian strike
Lydia hola sherpova Shields her brother
with planks of wood
he's partially paralyzed and last month
a piece of shrapnel ripped through his
bedroom the impact of the blast
shattered every window in their house
turning shards of glass into projectiles
can I use swear words a lot of swear
words she says when asked about the
Russian military we need to push them
out as soon as possible but in reality
this community can't push back Lydia and
her brother are trapped their City
unable to defend itself because the
Russians are launching their attacks
just across the river from this Nuclear
Power Plant
what can I say about Russians Who hide
behind a nuclear power station there are
no words says the mayor of marinets
Kennedy borovuk showed us the aftermath
from nine months of Relentless Russian
shelling hitting schools hospitals and
hundreds of homes knowing the ukrainians
wouldn't dare return fire retaliation
could be suicide
every night you go to bed you're not
sure if you're going to wake up this
resident says we're sitting ducks
unable to defend themselves at times
their resilience seems futile
halim is fixing the door frame to his
house that's been blown apart
[Music]
my wife and I are 84 years old where
else can we go like this couple a lot of
people here are vulnerable old poor and
sick those who could leave left months
ago around half the City's population of
50 000 has fled Out of The Shadow of the
nuclear plant
the Russians captured the zapparisha
power plant one week into the invasion
firing on the facility dozens of times
fueling fears of a meltdown
since then the site has been shelled
repeatedly with each side blaming the
other
it's a living nightmare we remember
Chernobyl and this could be many times
worse says this patient at the marhanets
hospital which is located just
kilometers from the power station with
its six reactors zaporisha is Europe's
largest nuclear plant chernobyl's single
reactor explosion in 1986 saw radiation
spread across several countries but
zaparicha's reactors are disconnected
and better protected than Chernobyl
experts say the greater risk is more
like Fukushima a serious but localized
meltdown that could spew radioactive
material for more than 30 kilometers to
nearby communities like marhanets
Russia has not only refused calls to
create a demilitarized safe Zone around
the plant they're using it as an army
base
there are no military targets here
they're shelling peaceful civilians the
mayor says my soul is crying we need
humanitarian assistance that cry for
help from this community is now being
heard by another 9 000 kilometers away
[Music]
Canadian veteran Rob McTavish lives with
his wife Cher and their three children
in Coquitlam BC and last year their
household gained some new members
[Music]
now living with four ukrainians from two
different families who fled following
the invasion it's nice just to have a
big group of us around the table it's
crowded but it's it's fun
16 year old Danny Bakowski came here on
a student visa leaving behind his
parents and four-year-old sister katsya
Danny says he cried for a month it was
hard I miss my sister so much
Rob's family connected with the
ukrainians through his neighbor Tamara
she grew up not far from marjanets
watching all of this unfold halfway
across the world well it was a feeling
of helplessness and just wanting to do
something to help
so over the summer they started
fundraising asking for donations
specifically for the marhanets hospital
staff here face the daily dilemma of
caring for the sick and wounded while
the hospital itself is hit Windows blown
out emergency rooms and infectious
diseases units riddled with shrapnel
struggling for basic supplies such as
bandages and modern hospital beds that
are easier to wheel into the Hall during
the bombings
we're treating people who've been
injured by shelling but we can't afford
to provide free medicine antibiotics or
painkillers says the hospital director
in January after months of fundraising
Rob packed his bags and headed east to
Ukraine traveling by plane train and
automobile through neighborhoods torn
apart
after a few days travel he finally
arrived for a meeting with Danny's
father
the two spent many hours getting
acquainted sharing stories about Danny's
life in Ukraine and in Canada
that really pulls at the heartstrings
nothing better that you can tell
somebody in the world than their family
is safe and okay
together they visited this apartment
building in the city of nepro destroyed
last month by a Russian missile the
killed 45 people including six children
block of I cried when I sent Danny away
it was so hard Danny's little sister
also cried because she loves her brother
very much
Rob stayed with Danny's Family during
his visit and one night their
neighborhood was hit by Russian Rockets
the sirens sounded
Danny's Brave four-year-old sister Katya
came to Rob's room and led him down to
their basement
a very emotional night and um
and she liked taking pictures with me I
got a really sweet picture of me and her
and the dog and that's when it really
hit me how
messed up his whole situation was that
this four-year-old
has gone through a quarter of her life
worried about Rockets every night
[Music]
Rob said goodbye to Danny's Family and
carried on to his destination arriving
at the hospital in marionettes with a
special delivery
[Music]
until we opened the back of that truck
it was a complete surprise
for the mayor and for those in
maharanets inside millions of dollars
worth of hospital equipment and supplies
shipped here all the way from Canada
thank you
x-ray machines operating tables and
dozens of hospital beds donated by
Canadian doctors and Community groups
the whole community of marhanets all
residents are very grateful to our
friends from Canada who helped our
Hospital the mayor says
later Rob took a tour to see how the
donations of beds and supplies are
already providing a Lifeline for
marhanet's most vulnerable
two communities families Worlds Apart
brought together by the horror of war
are giving each other the gift of Hope
you may not see Canadian soldiers on the
ground but I want them to know that
there's so many Canadians that that
support it's important for I think
Ukraine to know they're not standing
alone